science is magic that's real and now
physicists have managed to record
variation of curved space-time using the
most precise clock ever made
if you're new to my channel welcome i'm
brian keaton the chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics at
the university of california san diego
i'm an experimental cosmologist i'd like
to give you the experimentalist point of
view in contra distinction to my many
brilliant colleagues who discuss the
radical theories that shape our
perception of time space and even the
philosophy of life itself before we
unpack the most precise clock ever made
and the consequences of this new
experiment we need to understand the
concept of curved space time einstein
said his happiest thought was that an
observer in free fall would experience
no gravitational fields the implication
was that an astronaut accelerating
through space at one g could not tell
that he or she was not on earth space
and time and therefore mass and energy
are strongly linked together for mass
and energy we have the most famous
equation in all of science e equals m c
squared but for space and time it's not
necessarily as simple as that i'll start
with a simple analogy suppose you have a
piece of paper and you've drawn two
points on point a and point b
now let's suppose that you want to find
the distance between them the easiest
way would be to grab a ruler right line
the ruler up with both points and no
matter which way the paper is oriented
or even if you fold it up the ruler will
still tell you exactly how far away a is
from b but now imagine if instead of a
physical ruler
you drew a ruler on the same piece of
paper going from a to b the ruler gives
you the same measurement as the physical
one if the paper is flat
but if you fold it up in any particular
way the physical ruler gives you a
distance that's much smaller than the
ruler on paper does in other words you
the outside observer see the points as
closer together while the point a
doesn't see itself as any closer or
further from b than when it started
this analogy maps into the real world in
effect if i as the observer am on point
a on the piece of paper and some object
i'm observing is at point b
no matter how i try to physically
measure my distance from it i'll get the
same result as always because i'm always
on the same piece of paper as the
distant point so how do i know the
curvature of space time between us how
do i measure it in the paper analogy
what does the physical ruler represent
it goes by many different names but here
i'll call it what physicists call it the
invariant interval
the absolute distance between two points
in space-time and it's the same
independent of whether or not two
different observers are in relative
motion with respect to one another this
was einstein's key insight into what is
now called special relativity
the beautiful thing is by measuring the
difference between the invariant
interval and my spatial separation from
point b which i'm observing i can
actually draw conclusions about how
space time is curved between me and
point b
so there's the physical or covariant or
varying distance that i measure and then
there's the invariant interval that all
observers would measure independent of
their orientation or placement in
space-time
even more interestingly thanks to
einstein's key insight about space and
time being tied together you can measure
differences in perceived time and the
proper time as determined by the
invariant interval to do the same thing
the appropriate question is where normal
are they time and space are on the same
footing in special relativity einstein's
key insight a somewhat unfamiliar
conception
with today's technology it's actually
extremely easy to measure distances in
time it's actually much easier for us to
do that than to measure distance in
space thanks to the atomic clock
you see for distances in space
you need to set extremely precise
starting and ending points for every
point you measure in order for us to get
any insight on a small enough scale
experiment
and to measure very very short distances
could still translate into very very
large time differentials for example
light travels about one foot in a
nanosecond so measuring an inch is only
one twelfth of a nanosecond that's a
huge distance in time 100 trillionths of
a second approximately but that's
actually a very very difficult amount of
distance to measure so any uncertainties
in that can accrue to very large errors
in our perceived elapsed time intervals
but the atoms and molecules in our world
act as very precise clocks or timepieces
we can use that precision predictability
in time to conduct and create clocks
that measure the movement of these atoms
and give us extremely precise time
interval measurements
these atomic clocks and the principles
of relativity researchers from the lab
of jun yi
at gila laboratory at boulder colorado
have made an incredible discovery now
for starters this experiment was carried
out with what's called a strontium
optical lattice clock to put it simply
this is a clock that uses lasers in a
very precise way to create a stable grid
of light waves shaped almost like an egg
carton
strontium atoms sit in the depressions
in this egg carton keeping them from
interfering with each other the
electrons in a strontium atom's orbital
shells are pretty difficult to excite
they'll only go up in an energy level if
there's a very specific frequency of
light that hits them when those
electrons start getting excited we know
exactly what wavelength or energy of
light was exciting them it tells us
precisely what frequency of light is
being absorbed since frequency
in physics is just the inverse of time
one over t we can use the frequency of
the outgoing light as well as the
frequency of the strontium atoms
excitation to get an extremely accurate
atomic clock measuring the difference
between incoming and outgoing
frequencies
the strontium atom in this egg chord is
sort of set up by external potentials
electrostatic potentials which forms
inside this cloud of strontium atoms so
the atom's isolation from other external
effects meant that the researchers were
able to measure the precise difference
in time between the top of the cloud and
the bottom of the cloud here in their
laboratory on earth the top and bottom
of the cloud experience different
gravitational force fields but since the
atoms were all in the same cloud they
could isolate a lot of the noise and
systematic errors could be avoided in
their data something that becomes
extremely important when you get to
extremely tiny differences in time
intervals how small a difference were
the gila scientist able to measure well
for this experiment they measured a time
difference on the order of 10 to the
minus 19 seconds that is less than 1 10
billionth of a billionth of a second one
billion gajillion civilian a decimal
place followed by 18 zeros
and a one
this time difference seems small but
don't forget light in one second can
travel 300 000 kilometers so it can
actually correspond to a sizeable
macroscopic distance now these
individual atoms with their electrons
getting excited forms a quantum system
that is interacting in order to show the
effects of relativity
this type of experiment although not
this exact experiment could have
implications for the measurement of
what's called quantum gravity
taking a quantum system that is in a
gravitational field and exploring the
ways in which gravity affects its
quantum properties the real star the key
enabling technology was the optical
lattice setup that the researchers used
in their experiment these lattices
allowed them to exert an incredible
control over individual atoms within a
cloud of them yi's laboratory agila is
improving all the time
with this technology you can measure the
properties of gravity on an atomic scale
this will give us insight into the
behavior of quantum gravity there's also
the research into pure quantum mechanics
in a gravitational setting you see any
time the world an experimentalist or an
experiment interacts with a quantum
system it destroys the properties
collapses the wave function so to speak
in what's called the copenhagen
interpretation performing a measurement
this focuses it into one state
destroying its otherwise quantum or
spread out or diffuse level properties
as the measurement gets made this can
also include the effects of interacting
with gravity
so how this measurement will improve our
understanding of gravity and quantum
mechanics remains to be seen but the
journey has just begun
these clocks are getting ever more
precise and the control that
experimentalists have over individual
quantum systems will allow us to explore
quantum mechanics on the atomic scale
helping us to better understand the
nature of time
space and gravity itself
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
click here to watch this video asking
about whether or not physicists have
discovered a fifth force of nature in
addition to the two nuclear forces the
force of gravity and the force of
electromagnetism and don't forget to
subscribe